uh welcome councillors oprah on zoom
the apologies
uh we have today uh councillor abbott
and councillor lado can i please have
someone move that thank you councillor
crackit
secondary council lewis i'll put that
motion all those in favor
that is carried
[Music]
um no public forum
we have a couple of major late items
we've got one major laid item and a
couple of amendments
so the major laid item is the speed
review consultation document
and this wasn't ready at the time this
was published on thursday so can i have
someone please move that we received
this
councillor
and
mrs cook
thank you i'll put that motion all those
in favor
now we'll move to
the two amendments and these uh concern
the minutes from december 7th
meeting
and just make sure we get the wording
right when you're talking affirmatives
and negatives
so
um
i'm going to move these both together
can i have
uh i'm going to move that can i have
someone second that please counselor
clark i'm going to put that all those in
favor hi
thank you that now takes us to
the
those actual minutes considering
those amendments of the infrastructure
services 7 december i please have
someone move that they'll be
accepted
council lewis councillor skilt put that
motion all those in favor
and
the next is the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the
infrastructural services meeting 21
december
again i have someone move that please
who's that
counselor moved second the counselor in
munster put the motion all those in
favor all right hi
right now that takes us to
the
stormwater bylaw
okay do i have someone who wishes to
speak to that
karen
right
handheld
here
[Music]
okay the floor is yours
twitter karate councillors
currently mate you may remove your mask
if you wish to talk to me
currently the icc does not have
effective measures or controls to
support the improvement of invercargill
stormwater that discharges into our
rivers in the sea
we have a discharge consent from
environment southland that requires
council to improve the quality of the
storm water over the period of the
consent and this bylaw will enable
council to address this condition
we do not envisage this bylaw or have
much of an effect on the vast majority
of the ratepayers of invercargill
if the by-law is adopted
new construction will be required
sorry yeah your new construction will be
required to think about stormwater
discharge
and treat it if necessary before it
makes a way to the council networks
it is anticipated some existing
commercial and industrial sites
will need to complete some remediation
on these sites to mitigate the discharge
currently coming from their properties
was planning to consult with the public
from zero full feb 207 march
council will use broad engagement
methods to reach a wide audience
the primary focus will be on those who
will be more greatly affected which are
the industrial and commercial sites
council plans to engage with them
directly and utilize webinars which has
proved to be popular with the sector in
the past
hearings are planned for 22 march
deliberations on 0 5 april with the
council meeting on 26 april to decide if
it will be adopted
if adopted it is proposed to come into
effect on zero one july 2022
we're happy to answer any questions that
the council may have
um look my first question it's
again with it's with three waters now
when the if the bylaw becomes active
uh and the three water entity
takes over do they then own the bylaw or
does it sit with council
so who who then enforces the bylaw you
know the because they they basically
take over the 367 million dollars worth
of stormwater assets we have
counsellor i'm happy to talk to that one
um i think when we're all working
through exactly what the transition
measures will be um once a any new three
waters entity comes into place uh what
we're focused on doing is making sure
that we've got frankly our house in
order so that we can hand it over in the
best possible
scenario to those new entities
look my expectation is is that they
would probably pick up
any reasonably recent
bylaws
re-badge them put them through their
their process and they would become
those of the new entity um and then that
they would look to review those over
time but those are matters that we will
have to work through um that being said
though it will be impossible for the new
entity simply to enforce our bylaw
right okay
uh questions
council clark and this is a follow-on
from that
certainly the three water new entities
are taking over the three areas
including storm water but they've
signaled a post there
a new entity's coming into play on 2024
that storm water doesn't have any
conditions around the state they're
going to take over the operation but
it's sort of out in the future by two or
three years it's an area that they
haven't worked on yet at government and
i just wonder if there's any cost to us
to
um develop this bylaw are we going to
have ongoing costs until the new entity
picks up stormwater and if they are what
happens if we've over invested
in the standards that they subsequently
create which could be 20 24 25 26
onwards
and are we jumping in early
where other councils aren't given that
the new entity has a cross subsidy
impact
look i think um the
the team would say that they they aren't
going to an excess in terms of the
regime they are creating around the
stormwater bylaw
it's really around what we've been
asking people to do for quite a while
but we've really had no teeth to enforce
those people who sort of refuse to do
the right thing
uh the other piece around the the new
entities and the new reform package
is uh tamata arawai
and although they aren't going to be
i guess taking responsibility for
setting the
enforcing the standards around
stormwater they will be taking a a much
stronger view of making sure that
regional councils are putting in place a
good regulatory regime and that they are
enforcing that regulatory regime i think
most regional councils around the
country haven't been particularly
proactive in that space um they are
starting to be more and more
when we do have a an environmental
incident and they are inevitable nothing
works perfectly 100 of the time we need
to be able to say that we've done
everything that we reasonably can do uh
to protect our environment and any
effects of our network and this
stormwater bylaw is very much about
making sure that we are taking all of
those reasonable steps
and don't agree with any disagree with
any of that just want to be clear that
as a council we won't incur costs the
cost will be on the commercial and
industrial rate payers who will then
have to comply
uh that that's right in terms however we
will have some costs in terms of
monitoring and enforcing that that's
fine thank you
as we have a discharge consent
we are the ultimate discharger therefore
we have an obligation to clear up our
discharge
so we should be as proactive as we can
be
rather than being reactive
after an event
if we are going to be
good parties within the environment and
looking at the
land water forum
and the things that they are talking
about we are asking things of everybody
we as a community are expecting better
water quality
in order to achieve that we need to make
sure that we as a significant player are
doing our bit to make things better so i
think that
[Music]
we invest as a council
what gives us
comfort within our consent but also what
as citizens
that's better for the environment that
we all live in and i think to do less
than that is to do a disservice to the
place that we live
thank you
um well i've councillor kit
council sopa
a councillor kit
thank you mr chair i wasn't sure whether
you'd notice i was thinking i might have
to raise an electron i can
um i just wanted to say to me it is
about good stewardship
and i do note that our staff looked at
um
other councils from the point of view of
whether or not they had bylaws and it
would seem
the significant portion of our
neighbours do have storm water bylaws
to me this is all about good stewardship
and i think part of that good
stewardship is
if we are handing over to
the new
uh three waters entity that we hand over
as the best stewards we can be so
my feeling is that this is this is
timely
if anything it may be um less costly and
more responsible for us to have this
by-law
because i noticed that there have been
[Music]
i think it's 15
environments out and investigations
um in this last period since we got our
um
air consent
and quite a few breaches about 81 i
think so
i'm quite comfortable that we put this
up consultation now
okay and really quite quite happy to
move
um to move forward on it
right just one further question from the
chair um is council squeaky clean with
its asset
uh assets in relation to their potential
discharges or catchments into
the stormwater system
we're all good
um
[Music]
obviously we're enforcing a you know
bringing in a by-law that potentially
may affect what we do as well
um so we're looking to improve where we
can and when we can um
mainly through stormwater upgrades is
when we
look to
improve our discharge quality
um so that's our main focus at the
moment right thanks
council lewis just a very quick question
please the cumulative
effect of
half a residence watch at washington
cars in the streets
and then going into the storm water what
effect does that actually have or
the contaminants involved
um so sedimentation of the streams that
makes it hard for aquatic life to thrive
uh
soaps they strip oxygen out of the
waters
so especially now you might have noticed
an autopreneur stream quite a lot of
grass
that also strips the oxygen out and
makes it extremely difficult for aquatic
life to
to live effectively that's what i would
have thought but how are we going to
monitor it
i want to be patrolled driving around on
a saturday afternoon to see people
watching the cars and then prosecuting
or
so that's certainly not uh the intent
behind this i mean we want to take uh a
sort of educational stance towards those
kind of activities it's more of the
these sort of extremis
where you might have some of the sort of
heavy industrial sites
that discharge a large amount of
contaminants that that sort of
enforcement action would be looked upon
if you go through all the other steps in
place first to try and get to that level
thank you cheers
sounds a bit flippant i know but it's
actually quite a real issue
um that counselor lewis raised
and it came out when we were monitoring
houses for to see who was burning coal
and who was burning timber and went to
court
and we lost the case
because of new legislation peeping time
legislation
and you're not actually allowed to stand
out on the footpath
and observe the house
something really new
right okay
no more questions we've had councillor
sopa
move the recommendations which uh to
receive the report
note the options and the option that is
presented in front of us as option three
i'm moving option three just to clarify
chair yep yeah i assume that um
is that council adopts the bylaw
approach um
note that bylaw has adopted the option
to increase resourcing to support
implementation monitoring and compliance
will be addressed in the annual plan
and adopt the draft stormwater bylaw for
consultation noting that consultation
will take place between february 4
and march 7 2022.
so it's been moved can i have a second
to please
thank you mr coote
i'm going to put that motion all those
in favor
all right
against that
is carrick thank you staff
okay calling russell pearson to the
witness stand yeah
so we're going to move on to
automate which is temporary road
closures
russell
thanks mr chairman good afternoon
at the time of writing
we anticipated that we may have needed
some road closures for a couple of
events however given the change in the
traffic light systems
um
there's highly likely some of these
events may not necessarily be going
ahead however from a procedural matter i
would still like approval to close in
the event that they do need them um
obviously if the
events do not occur we won't close the
roads and there are two events the surf
to city event on the 13th of march and
obviously the anzac parade and it may be
in a varying forms but just gives us the
flexibility to be able to make some of
those roads
around those things at that for those
events so
i'm happy to receive any questions do
you have any questions regarding road
closures
council crack um i'm happy to move that
we go ahead and accept the
recommendation i mean we know that the
owner comes back to the event organizer
not ourselves and in the event that it
can go ahead then um
we should be permissive of that
thank you so much
three recommendations second counselor
kit i'll put that motion all those in
favor
against that is carried
so i knew you'd be staying on for this
one russell
we moved now on to the speed review
consultation
thanks mr chairman thanks for the
opportunity to introduce this um my
colleague david mccormick's our
traffic engineer with council and has
done lots of the uh i guess the
investigation and lead leg work behind
the preparation of this along with
rhiannon's team
um this report looks to a guest to do
two things adopt the speed limit
consultation with speed review
consultation document and to adopt the
draft bylaw which is the piece that
actually gives us the authority
through that consultation process to
actually
reset some of the some of the speed
limits
counsellors will recall we had a
workshop
prior to christmas where some of these
ideas had some discussion around what
our general direction was in this area
we're obviously at the next stage where
we look to engage with the community
what
a safe speed
will be and i guess that's part of the
challenge that we'll face is what is the
safe speed that the community looks for
this process is you'll have also seen on
the national campaign
part of a i guess a wider
approach from nzta which is the road to
zero which is really looking to
highlight to that all the communities
across new zealand how do we how do we
reduce the number of deaths and serious
injuries that occur on our roads i think
this
in the order of about one per day across
our country
i've thought a little bit about what
this is about and this process is really
about the first stages about our
consultations trying to understand what
what it is we're explaining to the
people um
and how that and how they will actually
receive that
changes in speed are something that will
take some time
um as we've seen with many other
significant changes to the way we
operate whether it be the alcohol limits
of the past it takes a little bit of
time for people to start to grasp what
we where we're going with this i think
the second part of that will be is how
do you agree what the safe speed limits
are for our community and we may well
have to over time readdress some of
these because what we've got maybe
maybe that people want less of them as
we go go forward and then as part of
that we then obviously need to go and
change them if we've got new signs we
have to put up we have to go through
once we've adopted the bottle but the
key areas that we see in this report are
really the principles and we've put
those in there so that actually sets
hopefully a guidance so people can get a
really good grasp about where we want to
go in time it doesn't mean to say we
have to get there tomorrow but it does
actually
indicate where we want to go for those
different types of roads
obviously there's a piece of uh
change around speed limits around
schools and there's quite strong
indication from the government that uh
a 30 round urban schools and 60 round
rural schools seems to be a real driver
and
um from lots of talk from lots of
industries it seems to be something
that's reasonably acceptable speed
around schools is something that we all
want to deal with
we've also got some speeds that we just
need to adjust in our bylaw and the
inner city obviously as we change some
of those streets are for people type
areas we need to address the speed that
we want people to go through there and
respect
then we start to deal with some of our
other roads and our urban roads
where over time
this consultation suggesting 40
kilometers an hour could it could be our
end target i guess the ideal question is
the wind target for that and as we get
into a rural sense we've got two splits
one for unsealed our gravel roads and
one for our shields and
the consultation documents generally
suggesting that 64 unsealed roads and
18l part of the research and work that
david's been doing has been looking at
what those mean speeds are nzta have
helped us quite a bit to give us some of
those safe and up safe and acceptable
operating speeds and we've based that
around this
there are also in the consultation
documents some minor changes to the
roading vital which are just relatively
small but are necessary to tidy up some
of the other aspects
i'm anticipating we will get lots of
feedback hopefully on this because each
of the groups who have an interest need
to come and
talk as part of this conversation
because that's the best way we're going
to get through to understanding what it
is our challenges are
what we do know is that speed is a
contri is a contributing factor in most
crashes what we do know the faster you
go the bigger the mess
um and what we do know is that we want
to reduce our number of deaths and
serious injuries
rhiannon is hiding somewhere hopefully
thank you behind us and
she would like to have a wee
discussion about consultation process
yeah just probably to draw your
attention to as russell says um we do
anticipate that this one is going to be
of high interest to the community and
therefore we've put together the
engagement plan to provide a range of
ways for
the public to engage
with the level that we're at and the
flexibility
that we will no doubt need over the
coming weeks i just want to reassure you
that we will be very flexible in terms
of how we
deliver the engagement we may well find
that we need to move more online
so we are ready to do that and to work
with the communications team on that um
so yes just to draw your attention to
that within the document
okay thanks man
open up now questions to russell about
uh about how it got made or rhiannon
about the actual consultation council
clark yeah
russell i can't see where overtire is
listed in here the odata school have i
missed it someone
i've had we look and and in the table
it's at the top of the
table in the consultation document and
in the maps
schools are shown as a little yellow
square and they are there the idea of
the the map is that when it's on the
website you can actually zoom down and
find it so yes
why i ask is that
people in nagatara tend to see
themselves as being rural where in fact
they're really just a suburb of the city
you know i'll see well i think they are
and so they there's the expectation that
they have greater speed limits out there
some of them are 80ks on the back
streets which is just ludicrous
um it really is
leading into an area that's around the
school just absolutely madness
um just to share an experience i went
through nelson recently um
for those who know nelson uh the rye
wangama valleys that lead into nelson
from blenheim from the blender
have dropped their
speed limit down from 100 down to 80
right across that area and in some cases
down to 60. 60
and major double yellow lines but just
tens of kilometers all the way through
and i spoke to one of the first
responders recently and they said when
they changed it they got a lot of
negative feedback law as you rightly
suggest but since then they've had no
serious accident and no deaths
on a stretch of road that had lots of
serious accidents so you know we will
have a struggle of trying to get
people's mindset down
i guess the other issue is i get a lot
of people say to me oh but there's a
hundred case you can do 110 120 is okay
it's only 20 over well maybe the margin
needs to be 80 and do 10 or 20 over
that's making it much more so
so yeah i think we'll get a lot of
feedback on this
so mr check on page 86 the
score's listed first and that's actually
intended
to be a 30k speed limit
so that's probably
something that the odata school we've
had
numerous discussions with them they'll
be quite enthusiastic about and we're
proposing on most of those skills for
them to be variable speeds so what that
means is that those speed limits will
only be on when the school
is i guess active so it'll be in the
morning in the afternoon so you won't
necessarily be slowing the traffic down
at all times but that's that's a
different sign so while we're on that
topic this is uh quite a key one are we
going to have those flashing um
red-ringed
sort of indicators that will
be on during that time period that is
the current proposal to have variable
speed
what we're looking at is putting those
sorts of signs on the
other principal exit to the school and
some of the some schools have two and
three
places you can get out so i guess it's a
to work with the
schools to actually understand how that
will work
rather than having fixed signs up so
right council lewis thank you
one of my my concerns about this is the
40k limit i totally agree with past
course there is a 20k
uh maximum pass the park school bus in
that area i'm scared that if we have a
flashing sign says 40k and there's a
school bus people are going to go past a
40k the 30k is
20k i think
no no 30k for what russell oh sorry even
30k
the bus speed limit passing speed is 20k
so if you have another flashing sign
that says 30k 40k whatever people may
continue that speed
and
you can breach off i see on 16 bar one
it does say other speed limits but
people seeing a flashing sign they
overlook section bar one in their menu
in the in the glove box and continue
that greater speed with a greater risk
of poland kid going into a school bus
council lewis has highlighted an issue
that has been worked on
in lots of areas certainly now in the
canterbury area they've got rural areas
where
passing a school bus on a rural road is
really quite
complex when people don't realize it is
20ks and i know they have been also
trialling a flashing sign on the back of
the school bus but you are correct that
we don't want to confuse the travelling
public too much so i'm hopefully the
flashing 30s outside schools will be a
good sign for a long period of time
our school buses are relatively i guess
limited places but probably the
the place that it affects most of the
traffic is certainly on queens drive
outside the james hargis jr campus where
there is an expectation that you need to
travel at 20 kilometres an hour past
those buses while they're loading
children
and not floating
also down here but street pass
thank you
uh
questions counselor skill
just uh thanks david and russell rhianna
for the work that's been done and also
the workshop we had was illuminating if
not
disturbing the workshop in the sense of
the stats were provided to us
without a shadow of a doubt i think we
need to take some leadership
and actually some urgency and priority
over this as a council going forward one
of the questions for you all is that at
that time of the workshop with the time
frames russell around the possible
implementation going forward it was my
concern at the time
and still is that
through process and consultation it may
be very elongated to actually get some
movement on this particular
issue um we heard you know tomorrow for
me tomorrow is too late for any last
loss of life to be honest it has to
happen today in fact yesterday's too
late
it's where i'm sitting with you so and i
know it's an involved process but
perhaps you could flesh out for us a
little bit more expectation around
time frames that we could uh at least
begin to work towards
david what expectation you may have
around that
without pushing to put you on the direct
spot that's all
[Music]
so i can talk about the schools so the
schools one's the easy one and the easy
one that we can talk about so the
schools is a document it talks about
within the next three years um so with
our eroding maintenance funding that
we've got
we'll be looking to go through those
over the next three years the schools
um and then
also for our city centre and suburban
shopping streets uh talks about between
2022 and 2023 in the document
hopefully that's easy to hear me
and then i do believe it talks about
for all of the sealed and unsealed roads
so the high speed high risk ones that's
going to be implemented in the later
part of 2023
and then the urban roads that we're
looking to the 40s that's the one that
we need to understand from the community
if the community are ready for that um
it would again come down to resourcing
and stuff but we would look to do it
probably just after those rural
roads because other other big winners
with the high speeds in the high risk so
that would be looking in 2024 if the
community was to
yeah buy into that 40 but we're not sure
whether they will be just yet
so just gonna ask you through the
question so david just from that is is
the funding part of the model the key to
the progress of pushing it forward after
consultation obviously
so is that a critical pathway the
funding yes and if it is is there any
way that we could expedite that from a
council's perspective
mr chair that we have funding
for
as part of our road to zero which is
part of our ncta subsidised program
available for us to certainly do um the
school signs over three years the next
three year window plus the signage i
think i'd also add
the bylaw um council sets the bylaw and
sets the timeline so depending on what
consultation and feedback you you get
you have an opportunity in there and as
david's pointed out
the transition for 40ks and all of our
urban streets i think's got to be a
thing we take over a little bit of time
because when you're driving down the
road it's got to read the right speed if
it doesn't feel like the right speed it
doesn't look like the right speed you're
not going to get compliance and not
going to get people to do what we want
them to do
we'll probably put it the other way we
don't we won't get them to do what they
want to do
so we've got a little bit of work in
places there so thinking about how some
of your
slower moving suburban streets would
work and how that
transitions we'll have seen other places
around our a wider district like in
central otago who have transitioned
already to 40ks and
it will be intriguing to fully
understand how compliant everybody is in
that area but
i think it's one of those things that we
will
grow and get smarter to deal with and
i'm hopeful that people will start to
understand that
it should be safer on our roads for us
all
thank you
council arnold i was just thinking uh mr
pearson um
if um during the consultation process
you get some people on certain streets
making um
making um
comments on um particular streets
like the the numbers that you've got
written in the document
are you
open to people
perhaps
saying well hang on a minute i don't
agree with that one that particular one
and that one there will go from that
that road here from say 60 cases to 80k
is that
part of the process or is this
it
so i'll take that one so yeah absolutely
the opportunity for people in this
consultation process is to provide
specific feedback in addition to the
feedback as to whether they feel you've
got the speed limits right so that's why
the submission form both online and in
the hard copy has the space for people
to write
because we anticipate that those people
that have local knowledge of specific
areas may want to make suggestions
in addition to what council has proposed
or differently to what council has
proposed for a specific road
um so we are ready to do the analysis on
all of those submissions to help you
then make the decisions that will go
into the bylaw
will that be explained in the
consultation document
yes it is explained within the document
and it will be explained within the
online form and the web resources that
will go with
the hard copy document
thank you yeah thank you for the
questions yes ms cook
is there any thought that
if
the public in general seems open to
those high traffic high-risk areas
for example um
windsor street or alice road around
new world
south city shopping area if there was an
appetite for to trial how it goes
without prosecution but education
sooner rather than later
so without too much delay
i think you could manage that in two
ways you could actually sit set a speed
and then review it
as we know setting of temporary speeds
is a interesting beast
and we would need to have one of the
reasons that's permitted in the traffic
control devices rules to actually be
able to set a temporary speed limit but
that's both those things are quite
capable of being done so
okay council clerk just as a lead onto
that russell um i noticed that dunedin's
um got their main street down to 30 now
i think
and that's created a bit of angst with
some people and potentially going one
way as well and leading on from even
said um
is xero
is there a case to be argued for not
necessarily
speed being the safety issue but more
how your manager zone like a cbd area i
notice when i travel through parts of
new zealand a lot of the
more progressive councils have now got
very low speeds in their cbd very low 20
and 30.
and so maybe part of our pitch to our
community is to show that this is not in
the car we're just going out onto bravo
limb here that other councils are doing
this as well
so they're factoring in pedestrian risk
as opposed to vehicle versus vehicle
uh absolutely um so that's in a way why
we are talking about uh both the cbd and
the suburban areas to show that um
absolutely these cities throughout the
country that are just slowing it down
for that pedestrian movement so
okay um i have a question regarding
the actual attached report it's
considering the there's a paragraph
there under the speed review and it's
entitled council proposed speed
principles
now
what it says at the end of that is over
time council is proposing to work
towards 40k speed limits in urban areas
and 60k speeds in rural areas now
we're going to
end up in a place where
you're driving down queens drive at 40k
past queens park and you're going to be
driving out in a rural area of 60k and
that's it
without because i
what i read at the first part of this
report was that it's going to be a
science-based speed limit for the nature
of the road its use and it's
but
reading that paragraph
it looks like it's just going to be
everything's 40 in town everything's 16
so mr chairman i guess i would respond
to that
and that
your residential streets
at target is obviously the 40ks where
people can live and do that um some of
your other transport routes
there is still that ability and
expectation that those streets will be
um at at a speed above 40 probably 50
um but i think that's part of for
instance the queen's drives and
you want to balance the to make sure
your city operates satisfactory against
it being safe and in those streets where
you have high speeds you need to make
sure the safety has actually got the
appropriate widths got the appropriate
lighting um surfacing all of those
things are things that will contribute
to a to that greater
safety
you may well at some of the
intersections like your traffic signals
where we do have at times people who
don't
follow the traffic signal colors
you may well put platforms in there to
change people's nature of how you deal
with it and that's quite a common
feature
um to have
small
bumps and into those as a platform so i
think you would deal with the the rest
of your engineering to
to manage that 50k is where you do it
okay
any further questions
um i've just got one for rhiannon
actually it's about the actual document
itself
on the page there where you put your
name and address and everything it's got
a
it's got the symbol of a traffic light
now
during the current environment the
symbol of traffic light means total
confusion should we have that there
i'm just going to look at the context
counselor oh it's just the picture of a
traffic light
i'm just
yeah
i do hear what you're saying i think
though from a comms perspective that
while we are now as a community used to
thinking about the traffic lights in
this new context we have many years of
thinking about traffic lights within the
roading context so i think that um
i think that we are okay that there
won't be confusion let's go on the
second step that's good i appreciate
that
right
we'll get back to the recommendations
and they are
that we receive the report
adopt the speed review consultation
document
and adopt the draft running and traffic
by law for consultation can i have
someone move those please agree to move
that way mr chair
we'll give this one to you thank you
councillor soper
and seconded ms cop
uh let's put that motion all those in
paper
hi against
that is carrick
right we have the
activities report
i'll kick that one off chair
i think we're slowly starting to get
used to the format of this report so
again it's a report of two parts leisure
and recreation and then infrastructure
i'll hand over to steve giblin to talk
to the leisure and rec portion of the
report and answer any questions and then
we'll pass back to myself for
infrastructure
steve
thank you steve aaron mr chair uh
councillors your worship thanks very
much just um
just a couple of points just want to
draw your attention to in this report uh
the team in the parks and reserves area
are undertaking the sandy point
master planning exercise and that's
developing the future
operating options
through both a combination of staff and
external engagement and this will be a
process that will be bringing back
updates to
this committee over the next couple of
months but obviously sandy point's quite
a large domain it's a big part of our
parks network and is quite a significant
asset that we look after so we'll keep
you abreast of the progress there
you'll also have seen
quite regular posts about the kiwis
choice award for queen's park so firstly
i hope you've all got your vote in
you've got until five o'clock tonight
we're also have undertaken the new
zealand gardens trust assessment as well
and we hope to be announcing both the
results of the kiwis choice
and the assessment on whether or not
queen's park retains its
parks of national significance status
hopefully within the next week or two so
again we'll let you know the results of
those
probably the only other point i'd wish
to draw attention to is the um the great
partnership we've developed with the
ymca
around our lifeguarding school
now not only has this helped splash
palace
with some of
the employment pathways around getting
our young people employed and engaged
and working on paul's side
but critically even if the star or even
if the people who have gone through that
program um haven't got employment at the
end of it some of them don't want it
they have picked up some amazing life
skills and life saving skills in
particular so we we're really grateful
to the partnership we've had with the
ymca we think this is quite a unique
program in the country
and pleased to say that i think the next
program is running out later this month
and already had quite a lot of interest
so again we're looking forward to seeing
those types of partnerships great but
happy to take any other questions
okay do we have questions for steve
council
um yesterday you've already signaled
this
and the last report we got and this one
as well there's no mention of the work
being done on anderson house
so be helpful to know what progress has
been made towards it i've been out there
it's looking pretty sharp
um and the other thing i guess for the
community is that people have an
expectation that once we've finished
that
earthquake strengthening and the water
tight
uh facilities and
removing the chimneys that it'll sort of
be open but that's not the case is it
uh look i i think i can answer the first
part about the work we're doing with the
anderson house trust and then i might
pass to erin for an update on the
progress of the actual capital program
but i
probably 2019 or earlier council ran an
expression of interest process
and agreed to engage and further explore
the opportunities with the anderson
house trust
manager of venues and events richard
macquarie has been engaging with the
trust members
on
progressing what use looks like for that
facility once it's
once the capital works have been
completed and they're now doing due
diligence on a draft lease and agreeing
terms you are right that this is not
going to be
entirely open to the public from the day
that capital works are completed
we will be bringing back an update on
what their actual use looks like but
again we are partnering with the trust
and we're giving them time to figure
that out uh as much as we're supporting
them so erin do you want to give an
update on the capital side of it
thank you steve
so in terms of those projects that are
actually i guess into construction
within our roadmap to renewal through
our project management office
those are reported formally through our
risk and assurance committee so i'm
getting some feedback
um so that was reported to risk
insurance in december
the anderson house project though is
currently still remains on track for
completion in april this year
are you happy with that councillor clark
you're just one question further for
steve and i'm not trying to be picky on
this but a lot of people don't
understand
if we can just explain a bit more about
the relationship that we've got with
with the trust
um
and who owns the building and
what options are available out there
because i remember the trust saying not
too long ago in the media that
they didn't see any sort of art
collection type need for the building
for the next couple of years they were a
little bit stuck
and around this table we had quite a bit
of discussion about
what potential uses there could be
boutique hotel
events weddings and the list was quite
extensive and i just wondered once we've
got the work done
where we go are we solely reliant on
engaging with the trust
are they the partners in this or is this
something that we could be doing to
attract
i don't know
live artists or something or
people doing a glass blowing or whatever
something that could be opening up the
building and have an interest inside
because it used to be just art but i
understand that the art people don't
want to go back to that
i think that's the exciting thing once
the
the structural works are done yep i
think
it's a blank it's blank canvas and okay
and we look at that
and and we got to see in same question
three months time
uh through the chair um i think
very good questions i wouldn't want to
speak on behalf of the trust at the
moment about the the future use and
their intent but i think with those
questions if you allow me we can
pass those questions on through richard
to the trust and
get a bit of an update within the next
month or two
if you're comfortable with that
thank you so the recommendation is to
receive the oh councillor scott will you
oh yeah thank you through you chia just
a quick up thanks steve for the
comprehensive report just
perhaps a quick update re civic theater
scottish hall and usage and under how
we're tracking with the
red light situation
uh yes councils out so that we've got
the numbers for those coming to next
week's performance policy partnerships
committee um but in terms of i guess
general operations
across uh you know we're following the
covert
uh framework at the moment um
and you know we're putting a bit of
effort into making sure that as many of
members can attend our facilities as
possible
and just to follow out of that just with
the staffing and the
i guess the mental health works
cancellation of events and venues and so
on how we
obviously that male is becoming an issue
perhaps yeah it's
i i guess everyone's in the same boat in
their regard around
managing the implications of the red
light setting at the moment
uh the team i think we're quite grateful
our team are
fairly focused on providing as an
efficient and effective service as we
can
um
and that's actually i mean i think our
team are doing actually pretty well in
that space
we are helped
in certain areas and splash palace are
doing a great job in that regard around
making sure we're keeping our facilities
clean
safe and uh
and getting as many young people and and
older people through those doors as we
can and we are starting to see the
numbers uh tracking up
um with a bit more certainty and a bit
more stability and we are seeing those
numbers um rise slowly
but from an event point of view those
limits are you know now are under red
light
they are putting you know they're
putting pressure back on that event
sector and the venue management sector
in particular
thank you
thank you yes council lush uh steve here
uh just as far as the bluff pool that's
now gone into a
community model do you still keep an eye
on that as far as numbers and stuff like
that can you tell or is that
is that just out of our our concern now
yeah thanks councillor uh we we are
partnering still with the trust
management and with the board there and
we are supporting them as much as we can
through this transition year
we aren't keeping a direct tab on the
weekly numbers like we would have had we
been operating it but we will be
expecting a report
at the end of this season on
how they how they went
we do
anecdotally hear from the trust that the
operating model is working really well
and it's fitting the community down in
bluff
um
it's serving them better than we could
in the same model and certainly that
operating model has changed a bit in
order to enable that to occur so we
think overall we think it's a great
outcome for bluff
and that paul's getting um i think
slightly more use as a result and that
certainly would be the feedback from the
community i think there were some
hiccups with some stuff over the
closures with chlorine or something but
it seems to be resolved i think
yeah and that's i guess that's part of
that transition year where we're you
know changing systems and changing
processes and implementing a new
structure is
always um exciting uh but that's where
our team at splash palace have still
been working quite closely with the team
at the bluff pool and i think it's gone
relatively well so far
okay thank you councillors um we're
going to now
i'm going to move that we
receive the activities report can i have
someone second there please thank you
counselor
were there any questions on the
infrastructure portion
no
[Music]
and put that motion
and put that motion all those in favor
all right all right yes that's carried
now that takes us to the
public excluded part
uh to receive the minutes of the
december 7th
public excluding minutes
thank you the press
and i now declare the meeting place
if you qualify